j'ai travaillé cinq ans dans la
restauration et du coup je me suis lancé
dans l'événementiel et j'ai commencé à
organiser des grosses soirées on va dire
dans des lieux assez restreint on va
dire et sans forcément avec les gestes
barrières et du coup ma question c'est
est-ce le rôle arrêter ça vous le
regrettez ou pas je regrette par les
biens non mais quand même je n'ai
justement c'est ça c'est ça le gros
problème ce soir
voilà et c'est pour ça que gabriella
talent est là aussi ce soir c'est que
c'est vrai que c'est le discours qu'on
entend on est jeune on a envie de faire
la fête et votre question elle est sympa
que vous voulez dire vous dites vous
allez aller où faire la fête maintenance
et saas et c'est ce qui vous est
exactement ça mais je me suis dit on
peut faire autre chose c'est par exemple
les gens qui prient de l'avion par
exemple il faut qu'ils apportent un test
un test du coc vide négatif de -2 3
jours et c'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
exactement pour nos soirées apporter un
test négatif de -2 3 jours et avec des
gestes barrières bien évidemment c'est à
dire le masque obligatoire
après les gestes barrière ça on pourra
pas mais dans tous les cas les gens
seront négatifs beaucoup vite donc on
pourrait faire des soirées des grosses
soirées sans que ces problèmes le jupon
après je ne sais pas vous nous dire
alors on a tous envie de revivre comme
on vivait avant on a tous marre de
porter le masque quand on est obligés de
le porter on a tous marre de ne pas
pouvoir faire la bise ses amis de ne pas
pouvoir prendre dans les bras ce qu'on
aime c'est c'est pénible et on a tous
envie de même en gpo être au
gouvernement j'ai 31 ans j'aime bien
faire la fête
on a tous envie de ça va donner pendant
un temps il va falloir ne plus faire la
fête comme on la faisait avant ça veut
pas dire comme l'a dit le docteur qu' on
peut pas se voir entre amis on peut se
voir entre amis si on respecte les
gestes barrières on peut avoir une vie
sociale
évidemment mais les grosses fêtes où
tout le monde est massé mais honnêtement
le change entend lever sur les tests je
pas sûr que ça soit à protecteur et que
ça empêche qui est des contaminations
d'abord parce que pouvait être un faux
négatifs comme on dit ça peut toujours
arriver je vois le docteur qui hochent
la tête
ensuite parce que pouvez toujours avoir
votre tête sans attraper le coronavirus
après avoir fait voter ce bref il faut
être très connu précautionneux et donc
pour être précautionneux qu'est ce qu'on
fait on regarde quels sont les
principaux moyens par lesquels le virus
qui se transmet et le fait est que quand
on est dans un lieu bondé quand on
lieu clos sans masque en plus on a une
proximité les uns avec les autres
bah là il ya des clusters de
contamination c'est à dire que le virus
se diffuse et encore plus quand il ya
des grosses soirées on parle beaucoup de
marseille moi je suis allé à marseille
cet été
pendant mes vacances je l ai dit c'est
tout faire un papa en vacances mais je
suis allé en déplacement là-bas pour
rencontrer les élus et pour aller voir
les gens qui font les tests parce que
dès le 17 août on savait qu'il se
passait quelque chose à marseille
moi j'y suis allé aussi pour alerter
pour dire faites attention à l'époque il
y avait des soirées sur des roues stop
qui réunissait plus de 1000 jeunes 2000
jeunes 3000 jeunes sur la ferme et ses
bars dès cette époque là parce que
voyait que c'était maria aussi des
clusters de contamination alors à paris
aussi c'est vrai il ya eu julian zelizer
comedia julia aussi qu'ils voulaient
poser que sur les doigts le relise bâti
moi j'ai juste une question
enfin c'est une question en fait je
comprends rien c'est à dire que je sais
pas si j'ai le droit de faire une teuf
avec 10 personnes avec 25 personnes
avec 50 personnes on me dit que j'ai pas
droit d'en faire mais de l'autre côté
est enfin là et en soirée à la fashion
week
il ya des défilés dans tous les sens et
les gens font des affaires je sais que
je défile beaucoup également
mais aussi j'aimerais je vois des fêtes
clandestines franchement il ya des teufs
clandestine partout dans paris mais
genre des rêves où on est des centaines
de personnes et il se passe rien le puy
du fou est ouvert mais alors derrière on
dit non ne fait pas ce dîner auquel j'ai
une question vraiment concrètes
samedi soir mon meilleur ami enfin autre
m'irait bien que julien fait son
anniversaire
alors qu'est ce qu'il y en a d'autres
qui ont nettoyé croyais à ma grand-mère
qui fera goûter aussi lui même les gens
de notre âge ils ont vraiment cette
question bien sûr monsieur loyal
anniversaire est ce qu ils l'organisent
ça tough ya combien de personnes ces 110
personnes dans un appart parisien voilà
on fait très mal non en fait non c'est
pas sérieux de faire une fille si la
question comme ça qu'on se bouge et ça
sérieux il faut lui dire et il faut pas
tout mélanger
vous étiez vous donner des exemples
notamment le puy du fou ou un défilé de
mode
comment ils sont les gens au puy du fou
devant un spectacle où pendant un défilé
de mode
comment ils sont ok ils sont assis
masqué ils sont assis et masqués est ce
que dans la teuf de votre pote pour son
anniversaire
vous allez être tranquillement tous
assis sur le canapé masqué par ailleurs
la singine pas non alors là je rebondis
là-dessus gabriela talent sûr aussi les
mains pour minorer les gens ils sont
assis ils peuvent être masquées et il
est généralement ils parlent pas pour
nos films et
c'est vrai qu'il ya l'industrie du
cinéma qui en grosse difficulté il va se
passer quoi avec les salles de cinéma
les salles de cinéma sont ouverts aux
mails vont rester ouvertes ce même si
parce que jusque là c'est vrai car et
aux problèmes il ya plein de gens qui
disaient au cinéma le théâtre et un rien
trop terne on parle pas parce qu'un
protocole sanitaire parce que les gens
ils sont assis et syrte leur masque si
le protocole sanitaire au théâtre bah
voila j'ai moi j'ai mon pote qui at elle
mal et il a dû annuler la sa tournée que
j'embrasse gad prochainement c'est vrai
que moi j'ai touché que j'ai eus japan a
clos hier j'ai tous mes potes voilà qui
sont en train d'annuler leur tournée il
ya matt pokora que l'on brasse maths qui
a aussi annulé sa tournée parce que en
vrai dans un spectacle on parle pas on
écoute le on écoute si on respecte les
distances et si on a un mas pourquoi les
salles de spectacle et ils doivent
annuler leur tournée pour enfin il ya
deux sujets parce que l'aller les
tournées dont vous parlez oui parce que
c'est des très gros événement plusieurs
milliers de personnes
oui mais là c'est vrai qu'on a dit qu'on
a fixé une limite qui était à 5000 qui
est maintenant à 1000 pour pâques et ses
gros événement parce que là ça brasse
tellement de monde d'accord que l'on se
dit qu'il peut avant d'être même s'ils
sont assis et qui avait voilà ça il ya
toujours un bon vous allez rentrer dans
le sable vous allez faire la queue vous
allez être dans un couloir bondé pour
accéder aux côtés question peut-être
mais c'est vrai c'est pas ces questions
bêtes c'est que ces questions que les
gens se posent aussi je reçois plein de
questions très concrètes sur moi
instagram sur mon tourneur les gens
permanence le pose des questions
j'essaye d'y répondre
et juste pour répondre à la question de
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu ce que vous
disiez sur les rêves les soirées
clandestines organisé ça c'est
inacceptable c'est inacceptable et ceux
qui organisent ces soirées clandestines
sont totalement irresponsables
ils peuvent être condamnés on organise
des contrôles je crois qu'il ya eu près
de 10000 contrôle d'établissements
recevant du public qui ont été fait
jusqu'à maintenant est ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que je pense qu'on va
accroître les sanctions pour ceux qui
organise ce type de soirées
clandestinement parce que on va demander
à tout le monde est responsable et avoir
des gens qui organisent des soirées dans
leur jeu grand secret où rien n'est
respecté mais alors est ce qu'on a vu se
créer un club d'amis qu'on garde genre
on se dit tout le temps c'est plus eu
dans ma vie c'est une très bonne
question parce que il ya plusieurs pays
et notamment la belgique qui ont mis en
place ce qu'ils appellent une bulle
social dire qu'ils ont dit aussitôt à
leurs citoyens
en fait vous allez choisir j'ai pu si
ces cinq ou dix les dix personnes que
vous allez voir régulièrement
et tant qu'il y aura là le
vous verrez c'est un peu de personnes
sont dehors elle a raison en fait à
gauche ce qu'on dit depuis le début
c'est il faut réduire le nombre de ses
contacts faut voir moins de monde mais
c'est vrai que si chacun se dit pas je
me crée ma bulle
avec 5 10 meilleures années ces produits